so i had a question from someone that wanted to
know what am i going to do with this constant
urge to urinate okay it's all the time not just
at night so there's three main causes number one a
uti which is a urinary tract infection number two
you have blood sugar issues high levels of sugar
now it could also be a pre-diabetic situation or
even insulin resistance we'll get to that in a bit
or a kidney stone so if you have a
kidney stone that can also cause this
so if you're male it could be that your prostate
is enlarged if you're female it could be because
you have a fibroid and of course
you can just have an infection
or it could be just a kind of a precursor to even
pre-diabetes now if you happen to have to pee but
you feel that your bladder isn't fully emptied
and you want to be able to figure out if that's
the case all you have to do is after you go to
the bathroom press just above the pubis bone
okay which is down in the front part of the pelvis
and you press in there and if you have the urge to
pee that means that your bladder is not empty and
that could mean if you're a guy the prostate is
slightly enlarged in which case you need to avoid
dairy products you need to avoid soy products
and of course you need to do keto and intermittent
fasting too and you will probably see huge changes
with that and there's two other remedies that
i would recommend in this situation number one
pumpkin seeds you can do that as a supplement
or you can start eating pumpkin seeds
right after your meal there's a
certain phytonutrient in pumpkin seeds
that not only helps the prostate but it can
also increase the flow of urine the other thing
you want to do as well is consume large salads
because that is going to increase the potassium
and also the amount of fluid that goes through
your body so you're not retaining fluid
if you're consuming foods high in potassium
it can act as a diuretic and the last thing
i would recommend for men would be something
called saw palmetto which can decrease the
very powerful form of testosterone called dht so
that would be the recommendation for that now this
recommendation is for men and women and it's very
important in fact it's the most important thing
you should do whether you're urinating
at night and by the way it's not normal
to urinate at all through the night as well as
having frequent urination through the day okay
the number one thing to do is go on a low
carb diet and really do it for real cut
your carbs way down i put a link down below
of what to do think about this fluid water
follows sugar and carbs so if you're doing more
sugar and more carbs you're gonna have more
water going through the kidney and you're going to
have excessive amount of urination so you want to
do the healthy version of the ketogenic diet with
intermittent fasting i put the link down below
next thing is if you have a uti not only will
the ketogenic diet help that but there's a couple
great remedies one would be d mannose take 1500
milligrams a day and you can split it up to the
day or one time it doesn't really matter the other
tea that seems to work really good is called coqui
tea and you can drink that to the day not right
before bed though and pumpkin seeds which will
increase the flow of urine and help you empty the
bladder not to mention large amounts of salad and
vegetables to increase your potassium so you're
not retaining any fluid all right go ahead and
apply this and put your comments down below hey
before you go real quick i have a course entitled
how to bulletproof your immune system it's a
free course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today